I'm exhausted Halloween is so overrated
Oh tell me about it
Halloween is the one night a year when a
guy can dress like a total [ __ ] and no
other guys can say anything about it Oh
dawn okay like what if I want to be just
a normal fireman and not you know a
stripper dressed like a fireman
well like 60 bucks for what it's like
it's a washcloth beauty ain't cheap come
on guys what's taking so long
I want to go do you want me to look hard
or not yeah give me a second all right
so what do you think
good [ __ ] or bad [ __ ] see I don't
know man I was thinking the same thing I
just don't want girls to get the wrong
impression you know but if you're asking
me I think you look great thank you yes
ready oh oh is that what you're wearing
yeah wait no no matter how much clothing
you remove you're still going to be a
freaky Bigfoot yeah II backups oh I have
an idea I don't know about us guys
everyone loves a sexy schoolboy
oh my god his cool balls his cleats are
killing my feet this is why I love
Halloween
nice costume very nice let get out here
yeah you won't be my car oh hey I am why
wouldn't want to get with me
that's not bebo Hey look so strong Leigh
Wow here I'm gonna happen just keep
going little boy